well the new york jets did what everyone
expected they would do 9 and 23 over two
seasons for adam gase not nearly good
enough to continue especially after 2
and 14. and they got dangerously close
to owen 16. the announcement came last
night christopher johnson the chairman
and ceo of the team announcing the gates
will not be back joe douglas the gm of
the team will indeed return and now the
question is where do they go from here
and
hovering over all of this chris
is that woody johnson the owner of the
team will be back on january 21. now
does he show up at the facility on
january 21
is he involved at all is he heavily
involved does he say to christopher
i'll take the keys thanks thanks for
your for your help you put a lot of
dents in the car i mean
this is not how i left it with you yeah
uh and there there actually was
from some in the league
there was actually a sense of
disappointment when woody left and gave
the keys to christopher because they
thought that christopher would do better
than woody he he hasn't done better than
woody but how involved will would he be
in this process you know he's got 16
days left as the u.s ambassador to the
uk it's not all that hard to be involved
in discussions communications
zoom meetings from the uk and what's he
doing he's pulling the train into the
station before he packs up and comes
home although it's probably pretty busy
you're packing up all your stuff to get
out of there but he's got time to be
involved and the question is how
involved will he be when he gets back
and will he be part of this coaching
search and it will be it be his guy that
ultimately is selected not christopher's
guy that that's something we don't know
the answer to now but the timeline
suggests he'll have the opportunity if
he wants it yeah well definitely i mean
listen he's a billionaire so hopefully
he's not uh packing his own boxes right
now i think he's well you know what i i
just stole a lot
i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking but
i i mean really honestly
i hope neither one of them make a
decision i mean that's just where it
comes down to me i mean i i this is why
you hire joe douglas
let him do his thing here yes you know
be there add your two cents be a part of
the process great all that stuff but you
know joe douglas you brought him in
let's see he's did some interesting
things with the roster
you know i know the year didn't work out
the way they wanted it to but i would
hope that the johnson family doesn't get
too involved in this process and they
let douglas you know continue his vision
for what he sees fit for this football
team with what he's building roster wise
and now he maybe he could get the coach
that kind of fits that attitude to help
that roster out
and really the big picture decision that
needs to be made now that you have the
number two pick you still got sam
darnold on a contract
for
another couple of years and justin
fields gave everyone something to think
about on friday night on a big stage six
touchdown passes playing through
whatever damage was done to his muscles
bones and or internal organs when he got
blown up helmet first in the second
quarter of that game you know i if jets
fans have to feel better but still you
got to make a global decision here do
you i guess you could keep darnold and
draft fields i guess i mean we you know
we talked earlier about the importance
of having two quarterbacks um but uh
this is the first decision that is going
to be made of consequence by joe douglas
new head coach and woody johnson because
by the time april rolls around safe to
assume woody's going to be back behind
the wheel of the team and uh you know as
much as they try to say owners don't
make those decisions they they make
their preferences known especially when
it comes to franchise quarterbacks well
yes and you know the fact that you know
they are they're sitting there at number
two
justin fields played really awesome man
if he could have another good game
you know this could work out well for
the jets you could have demand for the
number two spot for people who go wait i
want justin fields so there could be
that aspect of it and then of course you
could just say you know what we're going
to put you know and this is where i
don't think they could have like two of
them on the same roster because i think
inevitably that'll hurt you know the
value of one of them or sam darnold if
they do want to get rid of them uh but
you know i would think that if they put
sam darnold on the market here in the
off season when the league year
officially starts in 2021 that there'll
be some play for him so they can
continue some assets there too so that's
the big thing they're gonna need to
figure out you know that's a you know i
don't know i know jets fans seem like
they're at wit's end with sam darnold
i'm a little bit more of a believer i am
the team is crappy so i don't know he's
a tough he's a tough diagnosis because
of what he's had in his career and he's
been injured a lot but it's a big
decision for the jets
comes down to the vision of that next
coach and hopefully the coaching
candidates will be completely candid
about what they think of sam darnold on
the way in so everyone knows what the
plan is we got to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports